[Music]
[Music]
my name is Erica welcome to my Saturday
what it's almost Sunday man I'm sorry I
suck basically this week I wanted to try
something different
so you bros have been suggesting me that
I wanted to see what it's like to that
day of making videos in a day up in the
last book pimp I I'm a really bad
vlogger I feel weird vlogging I don't
like it at all but I thought it could be
you know fun or interesting for you bros
as a one-time different thing so yeah
let's cut to PewDiePie in the morning
and then I'll see you here when we're
done
good morning Bruce welcome to vlog a day
with palak I just woke up I'm really not
a morning person at all but this good
good look at this like it live pull
again right Chansey she always sleeps
like what I had underneath the cover it
[ __ ] yeah I thought yeah it's cute thank
you
and I'm gonna I'm gonna keep playing
some torchlight torchlight 2 for half an
hour
yeah I really have to throw my face all
this time I don't like this I'm
currently playing Lucius because I want
to get the bicycle there's you can get a
bicycle I think if you do good stuff
really boring to get the good stuff
yes the laundry stuff anyway I'll update
you when something special happens maybe
like like I got somethin happenin sighs
this is gonna be a fun day I'm still
making videos I got one more video to
make I think I'll make it
siren blunt card video because I didn't
make a horror video today I besides
Lucius a lot of people are complaining
to me that I don't make enough horror
videos but then people complain when I
play siren it is siren is as good as it
[ __ ] get when it comes to horror in
my opinion I think it's probably I'm
really loving that horror game but I
guess when people say oh he doesn't play
enough horror I guess they mean that I
don't play amnesia anymore that's what I
think at least I really like happy
wheels and amnesia I think is my longest
running series ever and when you play
something so much and just still try to
keep it entertaining it gets more
difficult and I'm I'm really not in the
mood to play amnesia and I'm really not
in the mood to play happy wheels today
so i Adam I don't think I'm gonna play
any of it maybe tomorrow
that's what I said yesterday I was like
ah I'll make a happy wheels video
tomorrow I don't really I'm really tired
like I feel like it oh hello I feel like
I need to be energetic enough to play at
the wheels or Misha because I'm kind of
crazy when I play those games I usually
get in the mood pretty easily like I
could be tired and then I started
recording and then I go crazy anyway but
it's it's high whatever like a barrel so
to get barrel [ __ ] barrel I wanted to
show you my parents
I asked I asked them to send like
Swedish candy because I kind of miss it
here in Italy so they send me so many
things
ghosts of land that are even like of the
blunder
it means like nice and mixed dim light
mixed up and dying that's good [ __ ]
right there miss dim light they have
human roll these are delicious I think I
saw Smosh Fridays and they were like oh
it's disgusting
it's [ __ ] delicious that's delicious
how can you not try again I like spicy
[ __ ] so I asked they even have these in
Italy actually I got three more packages
my my my my friends don't really
spoiling me that much I guess but when
it comes to like sending me stuff they
always they always go overboard but I
really appreciate it's really about that
it was my birthday gift pretty much so
yeah I'm gonna record some siren and
then I'll be back and now this something
that I usually do when I have extra time
because I think I'll have extra time
today actually is that you should be put
I just finished recording all my videos
so it's time to edit it's not five
o'clock I don't have a lot of time I
just played siren and I'm a little shaky
from it it wasn't scary it was just
[ __ ] disgusting I'm like ahhh
it was so [ __ ] this I think that was
probably one of the most disturbing
things I've seen in a video game ever
the Domus that episode it's probably up
already [ __ ] hell man down I'm done
editing one video I'm gonna take a
shower while it's rendering rendering
takes like 30 minutes so I usually do
other stuff while I wait
I usually do the thumbnails which is why
I put a lot of time with the thumbnails
I need to do stuff it's fast see ya
alright bris so this has been fun so far
it's basically me checking in
me and my said go into the cinema in an
hour
I think half an hour in soon last video
is rendering and 20 minutes left I'm
just done I don't hold the videos all
the thumbnails and pretty much just have
to upload it right now and put
annotations and that kind of stuff and
now it's 8 o clock so that means took me
8 hours today and that was a fast day
too so it should give you an idea what
it actually takes to put out my videos
each day I started at 12 I think ya know
it's 8 I don't think if I kept doing
this I think I'd be completely done in 3
hours but it's upload time now I don't
really have to do anything while the
video is uploading I can do whatever I
want
well I won't Wow I'm still shocked about
the siren thing it's still like to me
I am super impressed by that game I
think it's the coolest coolest horror
game ever anyway um I'm gonna go dry my
hair because that's what real manly men
do and everyone knows I'm a manly man
cuz you can't go out like this and
that's gonna be good
how's the cameras we are back is life
going really well I'll inject you
remember this I'm yeah yeah yeah you
have to do fun stuff part of the vlog
know me yeah okay I don't even know what
to do okay okay can we dance or
something thank you you saved in blind
I'm stick a Rio knows now the time is
then I'm gonna show the computer just
want to show my computer really quick no
one cares about you okay let's look at
life said they're beautiful
so so so awkward doing this so that's my
comfy Appa racer send me this for free
and they didn't even say say like they
said they were gonna send me like a
mouse but then this huge package arrived
and I'm like could it be because I saw I
saw some other youtubers got one sent to
them as well and yeah I was happy when
this came it's a really nice laptop oh
my god it's cool you know that's
configuring so you can't see [ __ ] we
have to go alright but go to the cinema
press I'm here final like last
last seconds we're really just now but
as always my videos not ready so it's
like this every single time I we go
somewhere do something like I always
have so much your settings will be saved
as soon as we start but [ __ ] each
other
[ __ ] you YouTube alright I'll see you at
the cinema it is perfect weather
yeah it's Silent Hill Silent Hill mood
going up look at that awesome do you
think they can hear hear what
keep up now with my car oh yeah thanks
we're gonna be also making food drive
over someone and I got it on tape no
yeah that would be terrible there's
people behind me going to the EPM to get
some money before the movie because you
need Moo I'm such a good farmer but I
thought we could have some quality time
in the main well what's up that's nice
but did you today you watch my video
like yours so how much am I the only one
who like I never take out more than 50
euro
I guess that's 50 bucks I hate carrying
money around I feel I feel like people
will steal it otherwise and I lose stuff
all the times I can't carry stuff around
that's just my opinion Phil Phil I don't
know so awkward filming in public you
have no idea you think I didn't care but
I care so give me my money Etienne what
do you call ATM in an english-speaking
bank mate bang come off this is such a
good flag
yeah
[Music]
we're at the cinema okay that's a listen
one I said I like 50 times yeah okay so
we just arrived at the cinema for Silent
Hill and I went and when is it starting
there's no one here we're gonna die
because we are the best huh in the room
hmm so I don't think anyone else is - I
think you're drunk
[Music]
here we are again breath and it's now 2
o'clock we just got back from the cinema
I'm really tired okay okay you can't
tell the brewery was very disappointing
kind of boring kind of I'm really tired
that's why I sound depressed I'm
actually feeling quite nice in my belly
because I eat a lot hope you enjoyed
this really thing and I hope it gave you
an insight what it's like to be Peter
pie I'm gonna go to sleep and then
tomorrow I'll gonna keep making bit yes
all right so wasn't that enjoyable okay
either way even though you might find my
life uneventful or boring I love my life
I love making dinners every day and I
love working hard on them and I know I
love to push myself with it and I love
to hello to go out with my girlfriend
and I don't know I I love my life and
it's a lot of it's thanks to you bros
and it's making this this possible for
me
so thank you sincerely I guess I really
mean it I do I appreciate each and every
one of you so much for making this
possible for me so bye dad
by that who've attended whatever that's
the best out Trevor salesman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]